bonbons chevron s'étendait jusqu'en 2013
sur 6 ha bientôt un complexe immobilier
verra le jour à cette même place mais au
8ème siècle c'était un hameau à 4 km de
la cité des turelles aujourd'hui il
reste que de sépulture alors là on est
essentiellement en train de fouiller le
cimetière de cette première communauté
donc on retrouve des tombes avec des
squelettes
à l'intérieur c'est les restes des
habitants de cette communauté de
beaumont qui vivaient autour d'une
petite chapelle qui est connu dans les
textes et qui s'appelait notre dame des
miracles en mille 2 et fondé l'abbaye de
baume ont réservé aux femmes sur une
dizaine d'hectares une deuxième fouille
mais à l'évidence la présence de
l'édifice à deux pas du petit abou
actuellement un mur d'enceinte le pool
mais aussi les dépotoirs
là on et voilà sur un dépotoir qui a été
accolé au mur de sud de l'abbaye à c'est
le mur de la clôture général et ils sont
venu creuser des grandes fosses alors
ces grandes fosses elles ont
certainement été creusé pour aller
récupérer du sable jaune bloqué en
dessous qui les intéressait et après ils
ont remblayé avec tous les déchets
beaucoup plus rare une troisième fouille
plus éloignés mais toujours un autre
cimetière datant lui du 19e siècle et
qui pourrait faire froid dans les
squelettes en eux-mêmes où il portait
des traces de découpe les crânes et
tessier défaut parfois horizontalement
parfois eux-mêmes verticalement donc ça
ça rappelle vraiment des exercices de
d'anatomie de dissection et puis on a
retrouvé des membres sectionnés
on a retrouvé les parties de corps on a
parfois inhumé juste les jambes et le
bassin on a parfois une image juste la
partie supérieure parfois juste des bras
et des tas de dos en fait découper un
peu dans tous les sens
c'était en effet le cimetière de l'école
de médecine de bretonnants des fouilles
archéologiques nous révèle souvent bien
des surprises